[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to ET live
today we're gonna be discussing all
about Jessica Jones season 2 I'm Liana
galera I'm ash cross we've given you
about a week to watch the season I hope
you did your homework and we are live
yes basically what we wanted to do is
just kind of have a discussion with you
rather than tell you every single thing
that happened we want to talk about it
exactly I'm not a feeling you guys have
just watched it we've just watched it
there's no need to recap the whole
season we want to hear from you so leave
us your questions your comments your
concerns do you agree with us great if
you disagree with us honestly even
better we want to hear from you we're
gonna be getting all of your questions
and comments on here and I think this
goes without saying but spoiler alert
boiler alert we're gonna be discussing
the entire of season two so here we go
right off the bat ash what were your
season two general thoughts you know
exactly I really hate to say this
because you know I don't I like to be
like happy beeps but I really felt like
it's really it was impossible to follow
up season one it was lightning at a
bottle it had a great villain what I did
like about season two though I thought
the character development especially
with Jessica was really really
phenomenal I really liked that what did
you think honestly I just felt like as
you said season one was so sensational
kilgrave probably the best Marvel
villain of all time was just such a
dynamic kickstart to this character this
is more of her origin story and I gotta
say it was one of the more boring origin
stories in the Netflix Marvel Universe
which is actually really saying
something yeah I and I I feel like this
is weird to say to in like the superhero
verse I just found it a little bit like
unbelievable completely which is really
hard to believe that that was a
storyline in this we will be breaking
down our double shots and hangovers of
season 2 which is everything that we
loved and everything that we never want
to see you again
but let's kick things off with a little
bit of a character breakdown yes um
Jessica had quite the sensational season
in that a lot happened but also not that
much happened at the same time yeah I
think it's like the 13 episode order
there's always there's a solid - where's
22 or three like I love you Netflix and
Marvel shows
sensational but honestly you don't need
a full 13 yes some seasons need 8 that's
fantastic if some are good with 10
that's great I really think that because
they stick to this 13th episode format
it really there's a couple things where
you're like this is stressed out this is
stretched out but exactly like I said I
did like the coke should we go right
into like the biggest spoiler of the
season spoiler spoiler spoiler spoiler
spoiler just as mom Jessica's mom is a
live life I don't know here's my problem
with it I didn't believe it the entire
time look I kept waiting for them to be
like just kidding it was so unbelievable
to me yes and I understand when you're
talking about a character who's been
experimented on as a child that's
already a little bit far-fetched that's
how she got her powers but the fact that
her mom was also experimented on and is
a super version of her mm-hmm and now
they're like they're this
mother-daughter two like duo of power
people it just I just did not really
enjoy it and I also found that although
the actress who played her mom which is
a different actress than in season 1
because they wanted to throw people off
yeah and of course she went through tons
of surgery and she was badly burned and
all that um I felt like that actress was
fine but I never was ever rooting for
her she never completely won me over
right I think the whole there's the side
effect where she has these like rage
issues yeah um that kind of took me away
from sympathizing for her completely and
it just felt like I mean I know this is
kind of the whole point was like
Jessica's like you're not my mom you're
not my mom but I also felt like she
wants it Jessica's mom and then we come
to this like back and forth where
Jessica wanted to kill her mom Trish
wanted to kill her mom the police wanted
to kill her mom and in the end massive
spoiler alert
Trish is the one who pulled the trigger
with massive like precision and aimed
they're up in a ferris wheel bucket
they're having this really nice moment
they did have a really nice final scene
I really liked I really liked that final
scene I loved it it was so great it was
harkening back to her childhood and
there's jessica sitting there with her
mom's dead body as the police are coming
up she's taking the blame for it acting
like she's the one that did the ultimate
sacrifice and killed her
for the greater good right but honestly
what did you think about the fact that
it was Trish who is the one that
actually pulled the trigger I mean what
I really did like about it is the the
ending of the season where jessica is
like you're just someone who killed my
mother like they are not they're not
good they're not in a good place at all
right now yeah but it was interesting I
mean she shot her in a ferris wheel I
guess I was wondering I guess I don't
know the answer if it was the Hellcat
because of her Hellcat aim now yeah she
has like very precise aim but I I wasn't
great I don't know yeah it was dark she
just got out of the hospital I'm
assuming you're delirious she had like
just a random pistol I I was expecting a
sniper rifle but hey good on you okay um
we're getting so many amazing fan
comments from you right now so let's
just take a look at some of them Melissa
says she just finished it she loved it
good I'm glad Felipe says it got a
little boring we agree with you you know
it's like those last two episodes are so
amazing yeah but it just I think it took
a long time I will say the last three
are we're okay here we go here we go
I'm Junior's sound choo is a major
downgrade from season one good acting
but horrible script dialogue and plot no
major villain era my comic is also a
major letdown
just an average season yeah yeah that
the villain thing was interesting
because I there was no clear villain you
weren't really sure who was I'm not sure
who was was it Jessica like what's
myself was it Trish like in fighting
within like the favela what's dr. Karl I
I'm not really sure which means it was
no one yeah and now you guys are
starting to talk about Trish which is
perfect we were just about to talk about
Trish Melissa says Trish with power I
don't know how much I love that and
Regina echoed her thoughts saying not
sure about Patsy with powers let's talk
about Trish a little bit the season I
feel like although we saw a little
glimpse of it in season one that she
would be like I would do anything to be
a hero really amped it up this season
she became instead of she became jealous
this doesn't like she broke up with her
amazingly hot successful boyfriend
because she wanted his job instead of
wanting to be with him and then she was
jealous of Jessica to the point where
she gets dr. Karl to operate on her
nearly killing her yeah I don't know it
was she was here I feel like Trish's
superpower the season was narcissism
yeah she really is just that it's a good
line thank you I really just feel like
her entire superpower was just like you
have Paris I should have powers but I
have to say half Malcolm
I should have Malcolm right yeah that's
not good faith and truth Trish for
season three yes this season like I feel
like the journey to get there what's a
little frustrating it was extremely
frustrating Regina says yeah yeah not
happy Trish was the one who killed her
mom we completely agree Madeleine says
do you know anything about season three
are there gonna be new characters
Madeleine we don't know too much about
season three but given the fact that
they killed off so many characters in
season two I'm gonna assume they need
some new series regular roles to fill
but can we just reduce really quick the
fact that Wilson I knew you were gonna
say guys I'm so excited
I've never upset over someone's death
but this is a fictional character and he
was the worst so can I say we called
that a season two career episode react
and pretty much all of our points where
were spot-on no props to you um let's
talk a little bit about hogarth this
season oh my gosh ash is not a fan of
Homer I would I was not yes let me say I
was not okay um this season humanized
her yeah a lot in a really really sad
and heartbreaking way you know she's
she's diagnosed with ALS young this
season but on top of all of that she is
so desperate to find kind of the I want
to say the cure because at one point she
when she went to take her own life I
wanted to take her own life quick and
easy be done she didn't want to suffer
exactly and then she meets this this
woman in Eze who was a nurse at the IgH
lab he says you know there's there was
another guy that another patient who
healed people and she puts all her faith
in this all her faith into these two
random people actually was a really big
turning point for hogatha who usually
has her walls up like that so I actually
as soon as she left these two random
people into her apartment I was like
yeah and she was super trusting and then
it was a complete con
total hoax and the moment she walks into
her apartment and realizes that they
have just like everyone she's a moment
right here was so gut-wrenching because
we knew that dr. Karl had told Jessica
there was no one there was no healer
yeah and I was just I was still trying
to piece together at this moment exactly
I just mean that they were gonna
literally take all of her material
things
yeah and just her reaction to it and she
just completely breaks down I don't know
it was one of the few moments of the
season I'd hate to say one of the few
moments that I got really emotional yeah
like I was I thought this moment was
really hard to watch you would think
that we would have gotten more emotional
over the jess and her mother scenes nope
but hogarth losing all her stuff it was
so sad I was so sad it was mostly just
that we saw that she finally trusted
someone and she had been through so much
and to have it was mostly that just that
that trust was stolen from her she
didn't care about the material things
even though all those Birkin bags my god
yeah but then she you know gets like
pretty solid revenge on those she does
what did you guys think of her revenge
on the two people was it too far should
she have done more I was curious about
that because I thought it was really
well played I I kind of found I found
myself rooting for her in that moment as
messed up as that sounds but yeah I like
that
she was like cuz I thought she was gonna
kill them with the gun and then oh no oh
no she had a whole plan to take herself
out of the equation keep her hands clean
yeah and still get her event and by the
end of the season she's now working with
Malcolm so let's start yeah I think all
about Malcolm let's digress there's so
many great show yeah Regina says can't
wait to see where Malcolm goes in season
three with price and their shadiness
because Malcolm he has these like really
quick arcs that keep happening like yeah
like his season one arc was so all over
the place and now in season two he's
like goes from being the kid brother
yeah hooking up with Trish to being like
super betrayed by everyone yeah getting
a haircut which as soon as he was
shaving his head no and then he shaved
it and I was like he looks handsome but
now he's kind of like an adversary of
Jessica yes yes Melissa says yeah I
think that price is gonna get Malcolm to
hurt Jessica I don't
think that he would ever do that I feel
like his loyalty loyalty to her is still
strong and is still there yeah I don't
know what did you think of price I
really could not I'm just gonna say I
couldn't stand it but really I just
didn't he didn't get enough character
development and my opinion to make me
care one way or the other about him cuz
he did a lot but I kind of felt like at
some points he was like a puzzle piece
that we were trying to shove in yeah it
didn't fit here's a new character
because we need one yeah I'm interested
to see what happens to him next
yes he's oh and Sarah you enjoyed the
revenge you said the revenge was awesome
yes so good to know that we're on the
same page very into it um but what did
you think of Malcolm and Trish hooking
up oh I think it was really hard for me
to wrap my head around because Jessica
was always like Malcolm you're my like
kid brother essentially a nutritious her
sister and all of a sudden they're
hooking up and I'm like you don't
actually like each other I I would have
enjoyed it more had Trish not been on
her will Simpson inhaler addiction kick
right did add that extra layer I found
the scene where Trish was trying to
convince Malcolm to take the inhaler to
himself really haunting and really
disturbed
I found that scene disturbing too
because she was essentially like trying
to get him hooked on something and then
he just turns and books it he just runs
away
good for him I know that could have been
that could have been really bad the next
thing you know like they're gonna be
sitting there fighting over the inhaler
and when it runs out one would probably
kill the other I was so happy when I ran
out yes thank God um we're getting more
and more of your comments right now and
uh I think that we should talk about our
double shots and hangover let's do it do
it alright guys so basically here's how
it goes um double shots are the things
that we you know love love we give us
more give us more of it hangovers are
self-explanatory we don't want one ever
again exactly um I've got to talk about
it it's cuz we haven't talked about it
yet my double shot of season two of
Jessica Jones kilgrave's return oh my
gosh yes I thought that episode 11 was
the episode that I finally was like
yes this is the show that I've missed
having David Tennant come back as that
character even though he wasn't really
there he was a figment of Jessica's
imagination as she's dealing with this
PTSD of having committed her second
murder was just so amazing I know you
felt the same yeah I really I didn't
like it at first really cuz I felt like
he was brought back as this like comedic
relief at first like they walk into the
apartment she's like she's like you're
not ready here he's like well neither is
Carl and I was like this is funny but
like aren't you like a rapist like well
he's an odd character but that was the
thing but then I saw multidimensional in
the first yeah and he is like he was
it's funny but like as the episode goes
on yeah she starts to face him in a way
where I'm like okay this is good yeah
cuz at first it was like devil on your
shoulder comedic relief totally but then
he really is like kind of haunting her
and I really really liked that a lot
what did you think so obviously kilgrave
came back because of the fact that
jessica is now dealing with this inner
turmoil that she killed a prison guard
who was tormenting her mom she covered
up the murder and this was really
something where we saw her not being
able to process the fact that she
willingly took this man's life and made
it look like a suicide
right I mean we've been we've talked
about this in a previous video what I
really like when a superhero cannot
handle the fact like I think a lot of
times we see these villains die and then
everyone's just like alright mission
yeah and I really liked watching her
kind of struggle with that yeah and I
think it's like the only I guess we've
seen Batman do that yes he doesn't kill
anybody but I just feel like a lot of
times when the when the bad guy got dies
we just move on completely and I really
like that it has an effect on her it has
an effect on her someone who always has
her wall up my other teeny tiny double
shot of the season was the little
glimpse that we got of Hellcat oh yeah
this season two finale so we see Trish
she's leaving Jessica's apartment
they're not on good terms at all no and
she goes and drops her phone and check
out this moment catches it on her foot
don't we all wish we could do that
seriously because all of us with our
shattered phones their shadow phones or
it would have slipped down in between
the elevator shaft and then it's gone
for good um what did you think about
that time
glimpse of Hellcat knowing that the dr.
carl experiment worked in some way it
makes me finish yeah it definitely makes
me wonder what's coming for next season
because Jessica and her not on good
terms like are they gonna be a villain
yeah are they gonna be opposing forces
next season are they gonna team up I
like this but I like the idea of I would
love them facing off I would love to see
a faceoff that would be incredible I
think that would be shout it out in the
comments if you guys agree and who do
you think would win ooh
what are your double shots of this
season oh my oh my favorite thing was
Jessica's relationship with Oscar and we
did not think we were gonna like him no
I didn't think I was gonna like him it
yeah oh and yeah there's a moment where
Jessica's like really down on herself
and she goes to leave her apartment and
he calls her and he tries to be there
for her and she's like no I'm going out
yeah and she starts to walk out and he
meets her so here it is yeah he meets
her at the bottom of the elevator and it
just holds her and I'm like oh my god he
loves her so much they also have sex and
paint paints with that really beautiful
thing at first she's like you've been
watching me sleep and I'm like so much
and this could be hurt her new family
and also his son there's a moment there
was a moment though at first where I
didn't like her no well he there's a
moment says he made a new shield for
Captain America shield get that man a
shield he's got it he made it so
adorable I love you as much as I don't
want to talk about the worst parts of
season 2 cuz I feel like that's all
we've been doing let's get even more
into it my hangover for season two was
Tricia's erratic behavior she was all
over the place we got to see her as
Patsy trying to get answers for Jessica
which I feel like the intentions were
good at that point but then seeing her
go through this downward spiral and
seeing the fact that she was just the
most selfish character of the show was
really difficult to watch yeah
it just seemed like every episode I was
yelling at the screen what is wrong with
you
alright it's one of those things where
you kept feeling like this is going to
build up this
there's gonna build something good and
then it just catch she really did
especially when she knocked Malcolm out
and put him in the trunk I mean we
essentially we watched this woman
relapse after ten years yeah oh the
flashback episode yes that was a great
episode okay that was a shining star in
the midst of a really bad couple episode
I did like I loved that episode and how
we got to learn more about how Jessica
and Trish related one when Trish was in
that time of addiction I thought it was
really great moment oh yay I'm REE I'm
remembering there were some gems this
season there are they were just few and
far between they were it was just it was
we had to get to them
yes there were there were many but in
that episode we also learned this is
this is my hangover all right um Trish's
mom kills and was like kind of trying to
reconnect with her yeah and follow her
around you know she like is her a tampon
at one point that was like such a weird
scene to me but also I was like I'm
being your mother but you know how like
it's you know that there was like a girl
in that writers room who's like you know
it brings girls closer together sharing
tampons in the bathroom I mean she's not
wrong we're getting more and more
comments from you guys right now first
went too far Trish went too far Melissa
agrees I love Oscar Andrew says whoo
double shots which I think Andrew just
likes taking shots I'm sorry to
disappoint you though Andrew this
beautiful concoction right here is apple
juice and Diet Coke because they're
still working um
they can't stay mad at each other they
need to team up but Jessica would
totally win a paper are you feeling
they're gonna like faceoff in season I
think they're gonna face off in season
three I think then time Trish is going
to beat her and then they're gonna do it
again and then Jessica's gonna beat her
and then they decided they should be
besties again throw your theories out
there I'm doing it you guys tell us your
theories Andrew said I love how we got
to see more of Jessica's past family
experiences um what did you think of
Dorothy the season
we've got more Dorothy than ever I don't
like trying to humanize I don't trust
her there were moments where yes you
kind of see the human in her yeah but
she was still like even even when Trish
was almost dying she still went and did
press
I loved that the journalist manipulated
her in that way and was like take back
the story because that's something that
in this industry they say all the time
was like a way to convince someone to do
it but it takes a really dumb manager to
actually fall for that line yeah so for
her she's part of much I feel like she
was smarter than that like come on
momager be better yeah um but overall I
thought that as we were discussing it
there were some some nice little nuggets
that were hidden in season two that I
really appreciated but as an arc not my
favorite yeah I agree with you um like
we said I just felt like it was just a
few episodes too long but there were
some really great moments I thought
Jessica's are like complete arc was
amazing yet her complete development and
like getting to know more of that
backstory would you know we were kind of
craving yeah yeah that whole thing with
like the college boyfriend was super
interesting it was like how she got her
leather jacket it's kind of weird
also it's not the same leather jacket
from Season one so nice of you to try
and plant that little seed but it would
have been better had it been the exact
same jacket yeah I can checked cuz we
like jackets we like Jack we like jacket
or wearing them um but I did love the
fact that they kept referencing the raft
yes because that was a nice Marvel
Easter egg and you made a great point in
an earlier video this is one of the
first times that they've said Captain
America's name normally they say the big
green guy right and so they're really
integrating themselves more and more
into the Marvel you know Cinematic
Universe right um the kids that was so
cute to me he made him a shield that's
so cute
well we are running out our time right
now but we really appreciate you guys
sitting down and letting us discuss all
of our season two thoughts with you and
we loved hearing all of yours as well
yeah we're still processing yeah you
guys are welcome to keep commenting in
the comments or you can tweet with us as
well because we are still thinking all
about it and we want to hear your
thoughts thinking what's gonna happen
with season 3 yeah and then we might
check back with you guys as we get more
more information about season 3 and
break down our latest theories once all
of this information has digested um but
yeah thank you all so much for tuning in
right now we're gonna drink this apple
juice and Diet Coke yeah oh god no we're
not she
guys - see you next time thanks for
watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]